le mercredi 30 septembre merci de nous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition du 7
8 le journal tout petit on commence avec
les titres de votre actualité locale
le medef ile de france vient de réaliser
un débat entre les différents candidats
aux régionales elle est tête de liste
était présente mardi soir pour un
échange autour de l'entreprise le
syndicat des patrons attendait des
propositions et des engagements attrape
des agents communaux tête en grève cet
après midi si il refuse une diminution
de leurs congés payés et puis je reçois
aujourd'hui pascal pieds-noirs président
du club d'alger de voisins-le-bretonneux
nous parlerons des foires aux vins
ces conseils pour éviter les arnaques
nous verrons aussi comment s'est déroulé
sa participation à la dernière coupe de
france bonsoir parce qu'elle est noire
nous reviendrons avec vous dans ce sujet
dans quelques instants
et le ton est monté aujourd'hui à la
mairie de la verrière le boxing club de
la commune protestent toujours contre le
retard pris dans le chantier de
rénovation du gymnase du bois de l'étang
la mairie a mis le club dans une salle
temporaire selon les dirigeants cette
décision leur a fait perdre plus de 40
licenciés
cet après midi ils étaient une trentaine
à manifester entre le bois les temps et
l'hôtel de ville le gymnase devrait
normalement être livrées en novembre et
je vous le disais en titre hier soir les
candidats la région ile-de-france ont
rencontré le medef une conférence débat
était organisé entre les candidats têtes
de liste et les antennes régionales
d'ile-de-france du medef de la chambre
de commerce et de la cgpme le thème
quelle région pour nos entreprises a
permis d'échanger autour de différentes
thématiques et propositions william el
est fanny bourdillon étaient sur place
c'était une première au niveau régional
les antennes ile-de-france du medef de
la chambre de commerce et de la cgpme
ont décidé de s'unir pour interpeller
les candidats de tous les partis à la
région ile de france
je pense que vraiment on a été
dans des sujets concrets dans des
questions qui ne sont pas des questions
politiciennes qui sont des questions qui
à la fois répondre aux besoins des
entreprises aux besoins locaux des
entreprises
premier point abordé la question du
budget et de l'attractivité un budget
pour le conseil régional d'île de france
qui représente 5 milliards d'euros je
crois que le grand combat de la région
c'est la lutte contre le chômage on dit
mes adversaires ont dit à 200 millions
de budget pour le développement
économique c'est pas vrai l'agent à 5
milliards d'objets et dans son budget
elle fait des transports de la formation
des lycées de l'université de la
recherche
tout ça ça doit être mis au service la
création d'emplois au menu des
discussions la question des transports
un grand enjeu de ces élections pour les
entreprises franciliennes avec le projet
du grand paris mais aussi le
développement du réseau urbain
le projet de métro du grand paris 32
milliards d'euros est incontestablement
en termes d'infrastructures avec la
liaison cdg express quelque chose qui
profitera à l'attractivité francilienne
nous proposons une baisse et c'est une
piste importante de la fiscalité sur les
transports aujourd'hui c'est 10 % c'est
le taux intermédiaire de tva alors qu'on
pourrait diminuer à 5 5% pour pierre
laurent du front de gauche 10 mille
postes supplémentaires seraient
nécessaires dans le secteur
pour emmanuelle cosse europe ecologie
les verts l'important c'est d'abord de
répondre aux besoins des usagers
est ce qu'on doit mettre l'argent dans
des projets pharaoniques ou est-ce qu'on
doit mettre l'argent dans le quotidien
il y en a qui vous disent on peut faire
tout à la fois madame pécresse monsieur
kalfon monsieur bartolone
non on peut pas tout faire donc faut
choisir et si on fait pas le côté si on
fait le projet pharaonique moi je sais
ce qu'il va se passer on frappa le
quotidien dernier point la question de
la formation au coeur du problème
l'apprentissage pour nathalie arthaud
lutte ouvrière il ne serait plus assez
protégé au vu de l'évolution récente de
leur statut le front national lui
préfère les rapprocher de la chambre des
métiers
il faudrait une sorte j'ai appelé comme
ça j'espère avoir prêté trop loin sorte
d' agences d'intérim des apprentis ce
rôle d' agences d'intérim serait jouée
par les chambres de commerce qui
connaissent le mieux et le plus près les
besoins de leurs adhérents
c'est à dire des artisans durant
heures les candidats ont pu exposer leur
projet mais surtout écouter les
propositions un premier dialogue entre
les candidats et les acteurs économiques
du territoire en vue d'un avancement sur
un projet commun au profit du territoire
et ce mercredi soir valérie pécresse
sera présente à jouy en josas dans les
locaux de hec pour participer à une
conférence débat sur le thème les
républicains les régionales et le rer c
siens alain juppé sera à lui également
dans les yvelines à chatou puis à poissy
pour un meeting dans le cadre de la
primaire de la présidentielle compte
rendu dans notre édition de demain
social à présent les agents municipaux
de trappes se sont réunis aujourd'hui
devant la mairie ils avaient déposé un
préavis de grève
cet après midi pour protester contre la
modique fit la modification pardon de
leurs congés exceptionnels
un reportage de mika et demi d'euros
elodie moines tension devant la mairie
de trappes après un premier mouvement
juillet les agents municipaux de la
commune étaient en grève aujourd'hui
plus de 80 personnes se sont réunies sur
le parvis de l'hôtel de ville pour
protester contre une modification de
leur congé exceptionnel
pour l'instant on n'a pas vraiment de
propositions on sait que faire la
proposition qu'on sait qu'il ya des
commentaires des tractations des
changements dans les attributions des
congés surtout les congés
retraite les trois mois calendaire qu au
bout de 30 ans de commandes et de
services les agents avaient droit
jusqu'à maintenant
et puis les congés aussi
dont deux médailles donc 20 30 et 35 ans
donc ce qu'on demande c'est de ne pas
toucher aux quelques acquis qu'on a les
acquis c'est pas compliqué hein c'est
les gens qui ont des médailles ont 15
jours de congés
1 les gens qui ont des médailles bah là
c'est parce qu'ils ont travaillé depuis
longtemps et tout c'est une
reconnaissance et qui peut
éventuellement faire la balance avec les
bas salaires qu'on a quoi selon les
chiffres avancés par la mairie les
agents communaux compte 36 jours de
congés annuels contre 25 dans la plupart
des communes les négociations vont tout
de même être mené pour tenter de trouver
un compromis avec les syndicats ont
négocié et ça veut dire qu'on sera
d'accord
à la fin de la négociation mais les
dossiers je rappelle que j'ai dit aussi
baddou réunion de l'ensemble du
personnel est toujours de réunions parce
qu'il faut maintenir le service public
on ne bougeraient pas avant le 1er
janvier 2016 toute façon avoir le temps
le temps de discuter
au total la ville de trappes compte plus
de 900 agents municipaux toujours
attrape la municipalité a voté hier en
conseil municipal la mise en place d'une
structure d'accueil pour les réfugiés
des appartements appartenant à la ville
vont être mis à la disposition des
familles qui demandent l'asile en france
la préfecture des yvelines peut
désormais hébergé des réfugiés en cas de
besoin le maire de la commune dima
longtin et le conseiller d'opposition
othman la chaux et est au micro de
michael ami de rohff
c'est dire que on était prêt à élargir
de façon raisonnable
notre capacité d'un curieux parce que
nous disposons actuellement de trois
logements qui sont derrière l'ancienne
passé et qui sont inoccupés qu on
démolira quand on fera le plateau urbain
ça veut dire que pendant une année
on peut les mettre à disposition à
condition que lié à un organisme social
qui gère qui accompagne les personnes
qui sont dans ces logements qu on puisse
accueillir des réfugiés de guerre de
manière temporaire là dessus bien sûr
tous d'accord on peut en parler
maintenant faut que ce soit fait
intelligemment il faut surtout que ce
soit accepté par les habitants en
l'occurrence là je crois qu'il était
question si j'ai bien compris que ce
n'était pas très claire de d'héberger
effectivement des réfugiés des logements
sociaux là pour le coup je pas sûr que
ce soit une très bonne idée
on a des gens qui attendent depuis cinq
six sept ans un logement social sur
trappe déjà être compliqué de la
expliqué qu' il ya des réfugiés qui
prennent la place à je pense vraiment
pas que ce soit une bonne idée
il ya des centres d'hébergement
d'urgence qui sont faits pour ça c'est
là que les réfugiés doivent aller et on
la voit sortir depuis quelques mois à
guyancourt la maison de l'étudiant sera
livrée par la région à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines en
janvier 2016 alors à quoi va t elle à
quoi va-t-elle servir et combien coûte
ce projet les précisions de sephora
namani la maison de l'étudiant est un
projet dans le cadre du contrat de
projets etat-région 2007-2013
entièrement financé par la région ile de
france à hauteur de 9 millions 8
l'enseignement supérieur qui ne relèvent
pas des compétences obligatoires
représente le deuxième poste de dépense
de la région derrière les transports
quand vous arrivez
du système
du lycée et que vous arrivez à
l'université l'une des difficultés face
aux quels sont les étudiants et on sait
qu'il ya un problème autour de l'échec
en premier cycle
c'est ce sentiment un peu que peuvent
avoir les étudiants d'être un peu perdu
la réussite étudiante dé prendre plein
de choses mais elle dépend aussi il ya
un facteur dont on parle pas beaucoup
qui est l'animation des campus 1720 m²
habillée d'une façade en bois pour une
structure certifié haute qualité
environnementale
celle-ci hébergera une cafétéria une
salle polyvalente une salle de
représentation avec une scène et
différents services d'orientation y
médicaux pour accompagner les étudiants
l'idée c'est que ce soit très ouvert sur
le campus que ça soit leur maison leur
maison pour créer de la vie étudiante et
donc de d'en bas ils vont trouver des
services une cafétaria pour pouvoir
venir se reposer manger discuter entre
eux et puis il y aura les locaux pour
les associations étudiants parce qu'on
sait à quel point l'engagement étudiant
ça aussi c'est un facteur de réussite
étudiante et donc des locaux pour les
associations pour les syndics un
étudiant après des travaux entamés en
mai 2014
la maison étudiants devraient être
livrés en janvier 2016 à l'université de
versailles saint quentin
une fois les finitions intérieures
réalisé et l'aménagement des espaces
extérieurs et nous sommes en plateau
avec pascal à pied noir président du
club donne envie de
voisins-le-bretonneux je le rappelle il
va nous livrer tout à ses conseils et
astuces pour s'y retrouver notamment en
cette période où les foires aux vins se
multiplient car de septembre à octobre
c'est la période traditionnelle
d'efforts aux vins les grandes surfaces
redoublent d'imagination pour attirer
les consommateurs avec des propos des
promotions alléchantes les caves à vin
profitent elles aussi de cet engouement
en proposant des produits de qualité à
moindre coût mais tous les cavistes n'y
trouve pas forcément d'intérêt regardez
ce reportage de camille lambert et fanny
bourdon
réduction conseils personnalisés et
dégustation chez ceux qui assistent de
voisins-le-bretonneux pas de doute
possible tout est organisé pour la foire
aux vins
xavier hippocrate organise depuis dix
ans des animations pour cet événement un
moyen de fidéliser sa clientèle et de ne
pas se faire oublier au retour des
congés estivaux ça rendez vous annuel et
puis ça permet de relancer un petit peu
la machine comme vous j'en suis rentré
de vacances ont repris le travail
l'entrée scolaire c'est pour amener les
impôts il ya le mois de septembre est
pas très drôle bon il faut re 20 ça
redonne un petit peu d'animation donc
alors qu'on pensait ne dit pas autre
chose
un rendez-vous qui représente 10% du
chiffre d'affaires annuel de cette cave
et une hausse de la fréquentation
pendant cette période
d'autres font pourtant le choix de ne
rien organiser à versailles quelques
promotions sont bien visibles mais pas
question de parler de foire le mot foire
j'aime pas beaucoup je trouve ça
dévalorise le vin je préfère largement
faire
de la promotion occasionnels sur des
nouveaux produits faire de la découverte
une décision qui ne semble pas gêner la
clientèle non je ne veux pas la voir où
va pas ce que je dis je à 80,40 mais
c'est non c'est non non je préfère aller
chez je préfère toujours aller chez les
petits commerçants grandes chaînes de
magasins au cab local la foire aux vins
a permis d'écouler près de 850 milliers
d'hectolitres en 2014 d'après
franceagrimer
avis aux amateurs mais toujours avec
modération et mélanie poker nous a
rejoint sur ce plateau dans quelques
instants votre chronique sur
l'environnement mais avant cela revenons
donc à la foire aux vins avec pastel
peignoir vous avez vu le sujet alors
est-ce que la foire aux vins c'est
vraiment l'occasion de faire des bonnes
affaires lors des bonnes notes safer pas
forcément parce qu'aujourd'hui l'offre
et est gigantesque entre les hypers les
cavistes
ce qui est intéressant c'est justement
ce panel sur une période assez réduite
de choses qu'on ne trouve pas forcément
toute l'année est alors bien sûr sur
l'offre je dirais nationale sur les
hypers l'accent est énormément mis sur
bordeaux tandis que l'intérêt chez un
caviste justement c'est que l'ensemble
de ces régions sont sont représentés et
là on peut acheter moins cher justement
les produits qui sont régulièrement
suivis par ce caviste si en plus le vin
nous plaît on pourra l'acquérir à
nouveau durant l'année et ça ça peut
être un moment de découverte puisque les
prix sont de 10 à 20% moins cher sur
cette période là qu'en plus il ya
quelques cavistes qui sont effectivement
dynamique et créer des animations
faisant venir des vignerons et c'est
toujours le vin est toujours un moment
de rencontre alors je le rappelle le vin
il faut consommer avec modération a bien
évidemment mais comment font voilà les
cavistes bush dont les grandes enseignes
pour avoir justement un panel de vins
différents et comment fait-elle pour
nous proposer de nouvelles choses en
cette rentrée
alors justement ce que je disais entre
les hypers n'y a pas énormément de
différences et de prix et de référence
sur la masse bordeaux alors après il va
falloir dénicher les millésimes qui sont
mieux puisqu'on est à peu près sur un 50
centimes d'euro près ou un euro on a à
peu près sur les mêmes produits mais ils
n'ont pas forcément les mêmes
les ihm alors si mettons pour pour un
vin blanc généralement sur l'ensemble de
la france c'est un excellent millésime
il est plus intéressant d'acheter un
2013-15 2014 voire un 2011 ou 2012
donc là il faut chine est un petit peu
et puis c'est l'occasion également de
sortir certains vignerons puisque même
l'offre hyper aujourd'hui à une dizaine
ou une vingtaine de vins de vignerons et
là c'est intéressant de suivre les
vignerons qui vont rentrer au niveau de
la sélection
tout dépend bien sûr de la politique du
directeur du magasin quand s'y connaît
bien on peut se permettre d'aller chez
des petits pianiste par exemple oui bien
sûr parce que là il y aura le conseil
puisque chez chez les hypers nous
généralement il n'y a pas de conseillers
très performant alors des fois il ya des
comment dire des personnes ponctuelles
qui viennent et quand quelques
connaissances mais le caviste lui et
c'est son métier il saura vous
renseigner
c'est une valeur sûre mais la sq il ya
par exemple quelques sera quelque chose
a décrypté sur les étiquettes
voilà deux trois think geek voilà ça
c'est une bonne bouteille à voir avec
modération bien sûr mais qu'on peut s'en
procurer
ouais ça c'est une évidence déjà quand
le vigneron a mis son nom son prénom son
nom où il habite sur la bouteille
si on regarde la marianne si on voit
récoltant ici ils sont 20 c'est un petit
peu comme un artiste qui signe son
oeuvre sur bourg voilà si je vois
embouteillé par mbd à 33 cents voilà je
sais pas d'où vient mon produit donc il
ya des repères comme cela qu'ils sont
qui sont importants et surtout le vin
est un dingue gouf et essayer de signer
votre bouffe emploi par exemple vous en
profitez pour voilà refaire votre stock
en premier pour le club d'oenologie en
cette période
oui bien sûr puisqu'il ya des comme je
disais il ya des références qu'on a
qu'on n'a pas forcément comme ça à
portée de main
et une autre énorme sur cette période là
donc c'est effectivement intéressant et
puis après voilà il ya toujours cette
quête du du meilleur millésime sûr sûr
sûr une référence on voit beaucoup aussi
les caves à vin se démocratise et
maintenant on peut en acheter qui font
la taille d'un frigo
est-ce que c'est essentiel d'avoir une
cave à vin comme ça pour qu'on commence
à acheter qu'on commence à investir un
petit peu alors oui alors tout dépend
effectivement si on veut alors ce qui
est intéressant sur sur le vin c'est
pouvoir le conserver de telle façon à ce
qu'ils s'expriment mieux dans le vert
demain qu'aujourd'hui alors il ya des
vins qui sont faits pour boire tout de
suite puis en a qui sont qui sont faits
pour être attendu et si on attend
certaines bouteilles
il faut effectivement qu'elle soit
couché il faut effectivement qu'elle
soit dans le noir sans uv c les règles
élémentaires et une température stable à
dire que on peut très bien avoir une
cave qui est un petit peu chaude mais le
tout c'est qu'on n'ait pas de choc
terminant températures maximales 19
degrés c'est dans nos habitations
on va voir un vin en fin de compte qui
va vieillir plus vite ça va pas nous
rendre un mauvais vin les fera le
consommer à dents voilà si la cave est à
14 15
voilà on va pouvoir conserver un vin
pendant dix ans si par exemple on a un
dîner prochainement et qu'on veut
impressionner ses amis
est ce que je sais pas il ya tête des
bouteilles des vignes divine qui
ressorte en ce moment vraiment un petit
conseil menace tout ce qui ne ferait pas
rater alors plutôt en conseil je pense
que voilà il ya de jolis blanc sur les
deux derniers millésimes donc moi je
suis un militant pour les vins blancs
aujourd'hui les vins blancs sont peu
souffre et on voit bien sûr contient des
sulfites comme les rouches mais on a
beaucoup évolué et les vignerons
beaucoup évolué sur sur la dose de
suffit donc on a moins mal aux têtes
comme moi même à la tête et pas de
crampes donc re découvrez les blancs et
puis surtout pensez aussi à carafer les
vins voilà c'est très joli sur une table
et ça révèle les arômes
voilà et puis après essayer de vous
renseigner sur le vin parce que parler
du vin c'est bien aussi et c'est souvent
une belle conversation à table voilà et
mais justement il faudra essayer de se
renseigner combat chez les cavistes ou
justement pour les foires aux vins
j'aimerais qu'on revienne sur voilà de
france qui s'est déroulé il ya quelques
semaines vous y avaient participé
vous pouvez voir revenir dessus nous
explique comment ça c'est ça s'est passé
justement un polo club de
voisins-le-bretonneux moins bien que
l'année dernière puisque l'on avait
remporté la coupe de france c'est en
effet l'exploit bien sûr dans la tête on
voulait faire le doublé bon ça s'est pas
passé comme on le souhaitait la partie a
été très difficile on finit 5e
donc bon sur sur l'ensemble de la france
c'est bien mais voilà moi
personnellement j'ai eu du mal à rentrer
sur cette partie j'avais qu'attache mal
partie c'était quelle épreuve qui
attaque la plus visible sur sur la
présélection ou ou si j'ai quatre
décisions à prendre
j'en fais j'en prends une bonne et trois
mauvaises puisque voilà à ce niveau là
on a souvent un choix on hésite et à ce
niveau-là aux trois erreurs c'est c'est
fini mais on a on a réussi à monter
quand même l'équipe jusqu'à la cinquième
place est-ce qu'on peut encore
s'inscrire au club d'oenologie et ce
n'est pas trop tard alors en 1re année
je crois qu'il me reste deux places
sinon tous les autres groupes sont archi
plein d'accord il vient écouter c'est
noté si vous êtes intéressé vous savez à
pascal chinois au centre alfred de vigny
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci
alors maintenant nous allons parler
environnement super lune lune rousse
lune rouge vous n'avez peut-être entendu
parler en début de semaine dans la nuit
dans la nuit de dimanche à lundi
c'était une éclipse totale de lune il
fallait par contre se lever tôt on
revient sur ce phénomène avec mélanie
poté qui elle a eu le courage de se
lever pour observer ce phénomène et vous
l'avez dit floral
il ne fallait pas avoir le sommeil trop
lourd pour ce devait lundi matin en
amérique du nord les clips a pu être
admirée en début de soirée chez nous le
phénomène a plutôt commencé aux
alentours de 3 heures du matin est ce
que c'est vraiment exceptionnel parce
que ce genre les équipements on voit
quand même souvent alors ce type d'
équipe c'est assez régulier tous les 6
mois voir tous les ans une équipe de
l'ue donc c'est quand l'astre passe dans
l'ombre de la terre et ceux qui marquent
c'est cette teinte rouge alors je suis
allé au latmos le laboratoire
atmosphères milieux observations
spatiales et lui en cours pour
qu'emmanuel marque chercheurs en
atmosphères planétaires m'explique le
phénomène la couleur rouge des éclipses
de lune
elle peut être plus ou moins prononcés
il peut aller de l'oranje pâle jusqu'au
rouge vraiment très sombre elle dépend
en fait de la météo sur terre puisque
c'est en effet du l'atmosphère terrestre
quand latex s'interpose entre le soleil
et la lune
donc ici on imagine qu'on ait vues
depuis la lune on voit petit à petit le
disque noir de la terre masqué de plus
en plus celui du soleil et quand on est
complètement masqué la seule lumière qui
reste c'est celle qui passe par la
dimension de la tête alors on l'a bien
compris mélanie c'est impressionnant à
l'oeil nu mais est-ce que ça un vrai
intérêt scientifique
les scientifiques profitent de ces
éclipses pour étudier la présence de
poussières de nuages dans l'atmosphère
de la planète bleue la lune lors sert
alors d'écran les découvertes peuvent
remonter plus loin dans l'histoire que
l'on peut imaginer tout de suite
l'interview à suivre natra de notre
chercheur au latmos un savon remonte à
l'antiquité grecque où effectivement dès
que les grecs ont compris que les effets
des clips étaient en fait non pas des
combats de dieu ou des choses que comme
ça mais vraiment des effets géométriques
d'ombré de lumière
ils ont compris qu'une équipe de lune
c'était quand la lune passée dans
l'ombre de la terre et en comparant la
taille de l'ombre de la terre qui se
voit bien c'est l'espèce de bord un peu
courbe qui progressait sur la lune
pendant éclipse dont quand on compare
cette ombre à la taille de la lune on
voit que la lune est petit comme à peu
près 1-1 tard de la terre alors il n'y a
pas eu que les clips ça observé cette
nuit là il me semble tout à fait floral
éclipse à combien sud est est ce qu'on
appelle un autre événement ce qu'on
appelle la super lune
il faut comprendre une lune plus proche
de la terre ça se produit tous les 20 ou
les trente ans quand elle est au plus
près au plus loin pardon de la terre la
lune est à environ 400 6000 kilomètres
au plus près ce qu'on appelle le périgée
elle est environ trois cent cinquante
six mille kilomètres qui en fait due au
fait que quand la lune tourne autour de
la terre
c'est pas sur un cercle parfait mais sur
une forme un peu allongé et donc la lune
peut être peu de temps en temps un peu
plus près un peu plus loin et cette
équipe seul elle coïncidait
avec un moment où la lune était vraiment
assez près de la terre ce qui fait
qu'elles apparaissent un peu plus grosse
que d'habitude elles étaient dix pour
cent plus grosses alors on est venu ça
se voit pratiquement pas mais ça peut
donner une impression un peu plus
brillantes ou un peu plus grand complet
de lune ordinaire et pour ceux qui n'ont
pas entendu le réveil ou qui comme moi
n'ont peut-être pas eu le courage de se
lever mener quand est-ce qu'on pourra
observer de nouveau ce phénomène alors
la prochaine super lune avec une équipe
ce total ce ne sera pas avant 2030 2035
mais il se passe toujours quelque chose
dans le ciel alors florane n'hésitez pas
à garder la tête dans les étoiles
merci mélanie c'est très poétique et
nous quittons malheureusement les
étoiles pour revenir à saint quentin en
yvelines ça c'est une bonne nouvelle sur
la terre ferme ou presque samedi à
l'association le joyeux moulinet proposé
un concours de pêche à l'étang du val
favery de coignières débutants et
initiés étaient rassemblés autour de
cette pratique empêchant brochets
gardons ou encore des carpes
c'était aussi l'occasion d'échanger
autour de la nature et les menaces de
pollution de l'étang une quarantaine de
pêcheurs avaient fait le déplacement
écouter serge pradines président du
joyau mot nine et les réputés peut-être
pas connu mais il est réputé aussi des
traces et a tardé
on a des menaces de pollution il faut
savoir que nous recevons les eaux
pluviales
nous avons les eaux pluviales nationale
10 donc il nous dit ware qui vient donc
il suffit qu'un accident avec des
déchets liquides époque qui tombe avec
une plume c'est un portable on retrouve
un peu les pulsions ici et c'est la fin
de cette édition merci de nous avoir
suivis rester avec nous vous avez tout
de suite rendez vous avec sephora namani
pour un nouveau numéro de qu'est-ce que
votre émission culturelle c'est à ne pas
manquer quant à moi je vous donne rendez
vous demain à 18 heures pour une
nouvelle édition de notre journal en
direct je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée